[Music]
a woman in rags emerged from the swamp
flanked by seven giant scorpions
carrying a baby she headed for the
nearest village to beg for food she
approached a magnificent mansion but the
mistress of the house took one look at
her grimy clothes and unusual companions
and slammed the door in her face so she
continued down the road until she came
to a cottage the woman there took pity
on the stranger and offered her what she
could a simple meal and a bed of straw
her guest was no ordinary beggar
she was Isis the most powerful goddess
in Egypt Isis was in hiding from her
brother set who murdered her husband and
wanted to murder her infant son Horus
set was also a powerful God and he was
looking for them so to keep her cover
Isis had to be very discreet
she couldn't risk using her powers but
she was not without aid circuit goddess
of venomous creatures had sent seven of
her fiercest servants to guard Isis and
her son as Isis and Horus settled into
their humble accommodation the Scorpions
fumed at how the wealthy woman had
offended their divine mistress they all
combined their venom and gave it to one
of the seven tiffen in the dead of the
night
tiffen crept over to the mansion as he
crawled under the door he saw the owners
young son sleeping peacefully and gave
him a mighty sting Isis and her hostess
was soon awakened by loud wailing as
they peered out of the doorway of the
cottage they saw a mother running
through the street weeping as she
cradled her son when Isis recognized the
woman who had turned her away she
understood what her scorpions had done
Isis took the boy in her arms and began
to recite a powerful spell
Oh poison of Tess Anna come out of him
and fall upon the ground poison of
Bethany advance not penetrate - no
father come out of him and fall upon the
ground
Brian Isis the great enchantress the
speaker of spells fall down o poisonous
nest ever hasten not poisonous master
tech rise not poisonous protect and to
tempt approach not poison of martyr with
each name she invoked that scorpions
poison was neutralized the child stirred
and his mother wept with gratitude and
lamented her earlier callousness
offering all her wealth to Isis in
repentance the woman who had taken Isis
in watched in awe she had had no idea
who she'd brought under her roof and
from that day on the people learned to
make a poultice to treat scorpion bites
speaking magical incantations just as
the goddess had disguise plays a
significant role in many ancient myths
why is everyone being so sneaky here are
two more hand wringing classics from
Chinese and Greek mythology
[Music]